what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to I
actually don't have a name for this
series because the one-on-one was the
sit down so I don't know maybe we'll
call the shoot the [__]
oh wait the YouTube shoot the issue
Emoji
YouTube
where I bring on content creators to
shoot this and the manosphere welcome
guys thanks for having me thanks for the
uh grift for the for the gr yeah Griffin
out here
um so a little background little intro
um Donovan sharp the man the myth the
legend you were one of my very first
Pals in the manosphere
um I was on his podcast how to
relationship or no not all women not all
women that was the name of it and he
brought me and a couple other girls to
say that not all women are like this but
a lot of us are
sort of a it was sort of a play on words
and when we say not all women are like
that or when we say all women are like
that we're not saying that all women are
the same right
um when we say all women are like that
what we really mean is that most women
actually you know what I'll just go
ahead and say 99.9 of women they operate
the same way within the construct of or
relationships with persons of the
opposite sex this doesn't mean that
every this doesn't mean that everybody
is the same no but women operate very
similarly and that's kind of what this
whole Community has predicated on yeah
and I think even when I was more blueco
coming on he Donovan did Red Pill me on
a couple things
um so MTR the man the myth the legend
what up half a million subscribers half
a million and 50 000 subscribers
something like that I stopped looking
it's stresses
especially when you're when and I don't
have nearly the subscribers that you do
but when you're going through a
subscribe fiber boom yeah oh my God it's
like you're flipping down oh my God oh
my God oh Jesus constantly checking the
dopamine hit is hitting like man look at
all them comments coming through but
when you're in that downward slope oh
it ruins your day I stopped looking at
the analytics after a while like
whatever I just post a video are you on
a downward slope
since the summer yes really I would say
around the time period since Andrew Tate
got banned oh around that time I've seen
maybe a 40-ish percent decrease of the
views on the channel which was my Peak
was around summertime somewhere I'm
surprised I see you all the time yeah
like I see your reactions yeah yeah yeah
so it's I usually
let's end the slope don't subscribe
subscribe to both these guys you guys
both kill reactions you guys are like
the two people I always watch this is
our first time eating butter yeah oh
yeah
pleasure yeah of course of course I
thought you were gonna do the uh the
peace after the first one I was waiting
on that my signature exit the viscous
energy there it is I was watching him
one time and Devin walks into the studio
right when you're like it's time to get
active and she said what and then just
left
I said wait I was like no no all right
all right you gotta get it popping you
gotta get the situation started man yeah
the content creation space uh it's
Unique to be sure but uh it's been good
to me man
um I mean I love it I love it man I live
a great life I don't have to worry about
money it's just it's been nothing but
great well it's been nothing but great
financially on the other side maybe not
so much but what's the other side you
know it's it's interesting one when
you've done this when you've done this
long enough obviously the bigger you get
the more criticism you get and sometimes
you go through periods in time where you
just don't enjoy doing content that much
and when that happens that's when you
got to stop reading the comments of that
nature so you kind of have to I just
have to kind of discipline yourself not
do those kind of things but you know it
is what it is so now Pearl right and I
don't know if you want me to tell us you
don't really even look at the analytics
like that right like when you post 10 to
12 videos a day you don't even watching
she pays someone to look at analytics
yeah and reports them to her yeah I wish
that's funny you know it's funny it's
like people will ask me like what's your
CPM or whatever and you have no idea
ask my guy I know I just I just I just
show up and have fun oh my God but
that's the formula though right when you
get to a point when you get I would love
to get to a point where I can just show
up and talk and have everybody else take
care of that that's the goal yeah but
see the thing is when I started making
money that was the first thing I bought
like I was on a credit card in July I
remember yeah because you know YouTube
is like delayed I didn't calculate so I
paid the people before I got paid I
didn't calculate it or I didn't think
about it and so
um like that was the first thing I
bought was people because I just didn't
see the point of getting really good at
any of these skills when I could just
have someone else and I could get good
at the content part yeah let me ask you
guys a question what do you think being
a content creator on YouTube has taught
you
like even like outside of the con of the
advice that you might give or the
entertainment like what is something
that you know today as a result of
building the business I think what I
have learned is that people are very
brave when they are shrouded in the
cloud of anonymity people are people
tend to be very very uh very very bold
when they don't know who when when we
don't know who they are most people have
negative opinions about everybody but
one thing that content creation is has
really shown me is that it's kind of
it's kind of another world on the other
side of the camera that's what it's
taught me
what about you
I say a lot
that's her verbal tip right
yeah so people know I'm listening yeah
but I mean but that means in
conversation since you've been born
since you can talk you've been uh
humming but you haven't figured that out
until people have been commenting off of
your homes yeah or when I did Vlogs I
was I would notice because you have so
much I used to do vlogs there was so
much footage I would realize how much I
repeat myself and like I'll tell the
same stories and I'm like how do the
people around me listen to me all the
time one thing that one thing that I do
is I'm always after I do a video or
whatever I go and I take a shower and I
watch I've got the I've got a waterproof
iPhone and I hook it up to the Beats
pill or whatever and I'll watch my I'll
watch and I'll listen to myself then
I'll then I'll go down to my gym and
I'll watch and listen again I do that to
try to maybe clear up any verbal tics or
any deficiencies I may have that's
that's I don't know what about you
um I think it's a combination of a bunch
of different things but the one I like
your comment around I think that there's
I think I often go into conversations or
situations with people just in general
with a cup half full type of mentality
and I mean I still do and I always will
do but I mean looking down in those
comments from time to time or even you
know watching the comments you know
after like Kevin died like after someone
died that's how you choose to
um talk about someone especially someone
that looks like you you know it's just
completely uh disgusting and you know I
haven't gotten deaf threats but I've
gotten death wishes though oh wow you
know which is you know I mean it is what
it is at the end of the day but I think
in understanding that when you have the
anonymity of the internet sure uh that
it is you know you start to get the
worst out of people it's crazy the worst
the absolute worst but you know also you
know within that learn how to have the
toughest skin possible and I don't
respond to the [__] you know what I mean
I just let it just go there's some I
would say there's two times where I've
said something
um in regards to all the [__] that I
see down in the space and it's uh after
Kevin died and looking at all of the
that was happening I'm make sure to let
my peace go regarding what I thought
about those people and then also too
when I had cancer last year when I was
seeing people uh upload videos talking
about that I did not have cancer you
know something that was a life-changing
situation for myself
those are the two times that I've
mentioned something about that but other
than that you know you got to have the
toughest skin in the world in order to
be in this spot or just figure out how
to ignore it you know like don't don't
look at the comments that's I mean and
you have to learn you have to learn to
not have antennas
um there there are there are just
certain people every time they're tagged
in a video they gotta watch it yeah I've
just I I don't I'm I'm that's just not I
can't be I want to know what people are
saying you so you look yeah I can't do
anything yeah I used to be I think when
when
um I had a full-time job at the same
time as content creation because then I
just still had my full-time job to go
back to but since now I don't work
anymore full time so now it's like well
if this doesn't perform it might affect
some other things that I you know I'm
trying to do in my life so now I'm just
like I don't even I don't even look you
know what I do I'm like telling
everything I'll click on the comment
section in YouTube Studios and I'll just
watch the comments but I won't actually
look at the Analytics 6 because if I'm
having just a so-so day and the video
let's say YouTube Shadow band some [__]
which they absolutely do they Shadow ban
certain videos because of the words in
the video or the title or something on
the thumbnail
um so if if so I don't look at the
particular comments uh excuse me I don't
look at the analytics because if it's
underperforming it's gonna mess up my
day right if it's over performing it
won't necessarily make my day better so
I'm just like just don't look till the
next day and that solves that well it
really gets tricky is when other content
creators then start coming after you you
know do you Google your name do you like
YouTube your name or you see just yeah
that's what I I just see the mention I
don't do I don't do that at all my
girlfriend Devin she's a web wizard SEO
all that good stuff I let and at some
point she has to do this because she has
to look up my name to you know to be
able to do her get you in there yeah
yeah but after a while you know she
became proficient enough at it to the
point to where she didn't really have to
do that anymore but she was still doing
it she's like Donovan I saw X I'm like
Devin quit reading the [__] comments
quit searching my name you gotta stop
doing that yeah but I mean hey man
um the way I see it is this is like like
I said we all live great lives to me
that's just the cost of business man I
mean and one thing about modern women
that I talk about all the time is they
want all of the benefits without any of
the costs they want yeah they want the
hot body without diet and exercise they
want the high value men without being
high value themselves well guess what
man if you want to be a content creator
and be able to make you know
life-changing money and to be able to
retire members of your family then this
is part of the price that you pay for it
is what it is for me I don't really mind
when people on like the feminists or the
whales or whatever make videos about me
that's fine it was harder for me when it
came from people in my own space because
it's like we collabed I thought we were
friends and then what do you think
drives that though is it because you
pass the subscribers that's it that's it
that's the only reason yeah it's so
crazy I mean it's because I mean I I'm
not gonna I try not to you never know
people's intentions or reasons but it's
a bit odd when at 20 000 subscribers you
were helping me
and then coming at a million now I'm a
problem when I'm like you were working
with me but I thought we were friends
that's just I mean I I don't know
um
it just
I don't I just when I deal with people I
I deal with people in good faith I don't
and this is a weakness of mine but I
don't like to question what someone's
intentions are you know because I'm
assuming that hey the reason you want to
call app is because you want to collab
but just like you said man a lot of
people you know they don't it's not that
they're supposed to have your best
interests at heart but if you end up
becoming more successful than certain
people then yeah they're gonna feel some
type of way about it so earlier we were
having a conversation about these
delusional women yes
do you think that the delusional girls
actually believe the things they're
saying when they say they want the guy
with six feet six figures six inches
yeah of course because I'm gonna just
say something from my experience doing
the show these girls will say they want
these men and that's true they want what
they want but they have absolutely
symptomed for men that were less than
like absolutely like I have seen when
you say symptoms you mean they got their
energy torn up by those I mean okay I
mean they have chased after they have
they have chased apps back severed yes
but there's a difference like a girl
some
kid like if they're some girls can sleep
with a guy and not be that into him or
whatever right but you you know when a
girl a guy has got a girl like hooked
yeah right you can just tell so it's
like a girl will come on my show and say
I want this this and this but I see the
guy that she's dating or chasing after
and he's definitely not any of the
things that she listed like me he's
probably got one or two things but it's
like they'll say these super high
standards but it's not what they're like
I'm like you haven't even met these men
what modern women do is something that I
like to call inverse projection the way
it works is when guys like us say
I want a bad [__] she's gotta have some
nice titties a matching ass Flats She's
Gotta you know she's gotta be all that
well what do women say oh my God you
know body positivity you know beauty
standards blah blah blah blah well when
and we as men we have no problem letting
people know what we want in women but
women always come after us for that well
women think that if they were honest
about what they wanted that we would
also come after them you understand what
I mean and so they give these
politically correct answers because they
don't want to look bad it's just to me
it's just a perception thing when it
really comes down to it man girls want
good looking guys to blow their backs
out that's just that's what it goes down
I I agree with you but I'm saying like
like a lot of the girls will say I wanna
I wanna date a guy that's worth 150k
125k 100 whatever it is but they've
never dealt with these men in their
lives that's the delusion yeah so so I'm
like why do you say these things if
you've never had it just because well in
in their mind well in their minds they
can manifest it right they can make I'm
so tired I want to talk about this for a
second I am so tired of manifesting you
know what I am the only girl that
actually manifests things I want to talk
about this can you talk about that
Tick-Tock thing Manifesto I want Tick
Tock you quit oh I quit my job after one
Tick Tock well I had a plan to quit and
then I quit too that's manifesting
I knew I would be good girl's a modern
woman
I would never say I manifested that
because you work for it if you want
things you work for that's it and half
of y'all are talking about manifest I'm
like what do you mean you're just gonna
dream it yes yes you're gonna dream of
me
why don't you try to earn a man like why
do you try to learn to cut like why do
you actually try to do things to get
there well here's the thing
uh even semi-attractive women like dude
American women live the best lives of
any class of human that has ever existed
now we do that is that that's the bottom
line if you're a mildly attractive woman
you just kind of float through like life
is great if you are a mildly attractive
woman women don't earn their attention
all they have to do is exist so when
guys when people like us tell them hey
you have to do X Y and Z they're feeling
some type of way about it because in
their minds why should I have to work
for something that I already get for
free yeah but they don't get it for free
because they don't actually deal with
these men oh you're talking about the
high earning guys well there's a big
difference they don't understand the
difference between central market value
and relationship market value just
because a rapper or athlete pounded
pounded you out doesn't mean that they
want to commit to you women mistakes
sexual attraction for relationships I I
get that but I'm saying like these girls
aren't even dealing with like they're
not even getting sex from the guys that
they because I'll see the guy that
they're hooked on and I'm like this is a
rapper from down
yeah yeah no woman want no woman is
going to say well I want the average man
right yeah average and this is this is
where the disconnect is of men and women
the average the guys are above average
in some categories I will say I will say
usually unfortunately the average woman
believes that she is entitled to above
average men that's why and again they
don't want to look bad in front of their
girlfriends well I really want a guy
that makes 65k and as and is five nine
they're gonna be like what the [__] is
he talking about girl you're a 10 you
know you should be able to no oh my gosh
that's what they did to me on sauce cast
really because they they asked what my
minimum salary requirement was what do
you think I should say to that
yeah okay what do you think I should say
to that
I think
I would say 65 to 70. that's what I said
yeah there you go so how'd they get on
you they were saying they were saying
like you you need it to be higher like
girl like that's low dude I'm like the
girl said that yeah the girls on the
show said that yeah
numbers break down yeah I know you know
the numbers break down top 10 man top
ten percent man should begin the top 10
woman yeah that's how the numbers should
work out but it doesn't seem like that
is because we just have so much
information around or surrounded around
Decades of this women's empowerment
women's Liberation [__] which then they
conclude that they are a 10 even though
they are little sized
[Laughter]
I was saying that I was like well I
never thought I'd dated like God that
makes six figures I never really thought
about it because most of the time you're
dating guys you're eight so it's like
and your question is what blue Kevin
Samuel's up because before there was
that content nobody would believe the
amount of delusion that existed in the
modern woman today but for him to be
able in live 3D dispel the [__] it's
a Master with it dude unscripted like he
was like 385 000 and oh like he had
he had like super hot fires record right
like his rap battle record the
disconnect unfortunately is that most
men are sexually invisible to most women
yeah and so when you ask women questions
like uh who do you think cheats more men
or women they say well men cheat more
well whether you think they do or not is
whether whether you think they do or not
doesn't matter they're only thinking
about the top ten percent men and so
that's that's how they view dating
through their scope it's only top 10 of
men that that's why they have that
illusion that blew my mind the 2080 rule
blew my mind when I got it yeah they're
like you're probably a little more
students it probably is but even 2080 I
was like we only look at 20 of men yeah
it's not even and then when they found
out because I'm tall right yeah that's
always the first thing people say when
they meet me and I'm like six foot
roughly and so I've always gone for guys
like roughly my height or taller I
didn't realize that was 15 of men yeah
yeah Pearl I gotta ask the question yeah
okay go ahead you're over six foot are
you over six four five eleven I'm
wearing heels I'm five eleven and a half
you're taller than the average man the
half matters you're taller than the
average man you make more money than
average man you do
you settle
what else am I supposed to do die alone
like by a dog and then you won't be
alone with the dog
but you're right that listen listen
facts are facts and and I said this a
long time ago my arm puts it much more
specifically the more money Cloud status
a woman makes the further she shrinks
her pool a potential Suitor I was just
having fun yeah I mean that's sorry I'm
gonna
I might need a visa I don't know we'll
see we'll see oh God I didn't care about
the Masters I think school makes you
dumber actually I almost respect men
more that didn't go to school they tend
to be smarter no offense was it a
sociology or psychology oh the psycho
yeah because okay but the story behind
the psychology degree was the English
volleyball gave me a scholarship for
school so I wanted to go play that was
all I cared about and so I was like I
want a major that's easy
it's modern women right right it makes
no money
I didn't care about I was trying to make
money plans she's quitting after one
Tick Tock video that's it holy moly
I'm the only girl that manifests
and a manifest girl so so I was trying
to think because I didn't care about the
degree I just like it was it was free
right it was school like volleyball so
it was I mean it wasn't free it was it
was cheap let's just say yeah and so in
my head I'm like well
I could get my Master's Degree I want to
get it in something that's easy and I
was like all the psychology students in
undergrad had the easiest I was economic
so I had a real major for undergrad okay
yeah but then I did post grad I was like
I'm not trying to work that hard this
degree did nothing it's like I was like
this is like like what did it give me
like nothing well I mean it was kind of
sort of the jumping off point in the
Genesis of you creating that little
Community there in London and I'll look
at you yeah yeah the not the degree
though that was volleyball right so but
where do you stand with that by the way
I mean are we going to be are you going
to be pearly things forever because a
lot of guys and here I'm gonna make this
prediction I'm gonna make two
predictions number one you are going to
be engaged by the end of this year of
that I am certain that's my first
prediction my second prediction my
second prediction look she's blushing my
second prediction well well and I'll
I'll tell you why here in just a second
my second prediction is that you're not
gonna do this forever nobody's gonna do
this forever if and you been open about
the fact that you want to you know
eventually want to get married and start
a family I mean you can't serve two Gods
um and so you know you're going to have
your challenges but I don't think you're
I don't think you're going to have any
shortage of of potential suitors out
there even though the pool is very small
you have a big enough platform to wear
more people know and understand you and
if you are getting DMs I can Pro I can
promise you that the intentions for guys
sliding into your DMs are very different
from the guys sliding into Brittany
renner's DMS are you dating now Pearl
yeah yeah
I'm not dating like I don't have I'm not
dating anyone but like okay I'm like I
mean we'll see so oh oh breaking news
breaking news breaking news did anyone
else know that what that you're dating
right now I mean like I'm saying I'm
like open to I don't know oh you're open
to it you don't have like a special
oh okay let's not wait a minute oh oh oh
look breaking
either way
um like I said and the reason why I
think you're going to be engaged by the
end of the year and and you said it was
funny we had this conversation you said
you didn't realize that you're still
market value until you talked to Kevin
right yeah that's what I mean most like
most American modern women they have
tattoos a lot of them have children out
of wedlock a lot of them have exorbitant
body counts
Etc et cetera you don't appear to have
any of those things and I'll tell you
this let's just say in some alternate
universe that you had a 75 body count
there's precious there is precious
little evidence of that in front of us I
say all the time never dude ladies lie
about your body count lie your ass off
but if you tell a guy that you banged
seven guys you better act like you've
banged seven guys you can say well I've
got a body count of seven and then
you're posting pictures of you on a
yacht on Instagram those don't work but
that's the reason why I'm sure that
you're going to be engaging I'm getting
engaged by that we'll see yeah
um that's why I got trust issues why I'm
just gonna just lie to me dude I don't
wanna I don't want to I told you guys I
we were having this conversation off the
air I was like do you know how many guys
my girlfriend Devin has slept with we
will never ever know I don't want to
know I don't care to know they always
divide by three what do you think of
okay when you're thinking about multiply
that by 17. I mean I feel like men are
like practical so it's kind of like what
is a guy gonna do like spend his time
asking questions that like no yeah
that's that's the thing I have to
observe and see this is what guys don't
do we say modern women are lazy men are
lazy too there's not a series of
questions that you can ask women that's
going to give you information about our
body count because she is going to lie
women always lie here's another thing
when you're asking these questions women
know what you're getting at what men
have to do what men have to do one thing
that men have that women do not we have
more of the luxury of time a lot of guys
after six months okay so she's great in
the sack she's got a great body and this
not the other she's wife of material no
bruh you need to vet women for no less
than 12 months and then at that point if
you're paying attention you have the
right knowledge then you might be able
to accurately and it's not even about
you know naming her body count is she a
hoe or not that's what it comes down to
do you guys agree with the phrase it's
not about the number but the number of
Alphas
that she's been with because that's what
Rolo talks about a lot like so he'll
he'll always this is the example he
gives okay you know what I agree with
this there's a girl with a five body
count but one was Michael B Jordan one
was Jason Momoa there's no coming back
from that she's done even at two five
whatever it is that where it's like if a
girl has I don't know 20 but they're all
less than you like it's all about being
the girl the best that a girl has had
Bingo do you think that's you think
that's 100 true I think both still
matter
if she's been with a hundred different
dudes I don't want it anyway well I mean
I
don't know like well
well to me it's a matter of probability
that guys trust me there's gonna be some
above average sausages in that rotation
yeah and and this is and that and it's
it's it is about the number and the size
but again it's probabilities if I mean
if I felt let's just say that I found
out uh uh Devin with Ken Jung right
I wouldn't be tripping I really wouldn't
I wouldn't trip I really wouldn't who
Ken Jung the guy from uh hangover the
Asian guy the yeah
that goes back to our first conversation
yes if she says I have a confession to
make I I had a thing with Ken Jeong I'm
not tripping uh who who think of a
celebrity like if you were dating a girl
think of a celebrity that your girl
confirmed that she smashed that you
wouldn't care think about that
not the rock okay not the rock not Chris
Evans no I'll be I don't know I've dealt
with a couple of girls in the past that
have been around so yeah with
celebrities and I think at the point
that I hear that
I'm like oh she's for the streets like I
had this one young lady that I met her
in the mall this had to be over 10 years
ago and um you know so real pretty got
her back to the crib you know sitting
Vibe and talking and then she she
proceeds to tell me that she was on tour
with Plies oh [__] and I was like
are you talented like did you have you
as like the second runner like what
Talent dude are you rap what are we
doing she was like no I was like oh God
now you know obviously at that
particular Junction I'm like okay she's
for the streets and she was strictly for
recreational use only you know what I'm
saying so like but I haven't really
thought about the alpha Widow thing to
that extent of of like it being a
certain height length width of a dude
and I usually don't go into that type of
thought but like I don't think it's
about like this alone though it's like
It's gotta be a lot no it's like it's
like she has to view you as the best
that she could do so like I feel like
she has to view you as the like the best
out of her exes basically yeah yeah
that's that's who you're competing with
and I remember Tate said this
um he said this on your show
and I'll sort of double it back to this
women and this will sound crazy but
women can you can take a woman's
virginity in so many ways you can take
it actually but we know that most guys
are never going to take a woman's
birthday right but you can you can you
can take her virginity as far as an
experience is concerned for example my
girlfriend Devin she's never been out of
the country the first time we leave the
country the first time we leave the
country will be the first time she's
left the country she's never stayed in a
uh in a you know two thousand dollar a
night Vegas hotel suite she's never like
it it it it gives me great pleasure to
know that this appears to be the first
time that she's done these things just
like Tate said men we want to be the
first to we want to be the first to give
certain experiences to a girl that way
she doesn't have anything else to
compare it to we value in uh innocence
and to a degree it's like ignorance is
bliss yes yes because they don't that's
why they say like you know the more
sexual partners that she has the more
likely that divorce is going to happen
and um yeah I mean I don't know I just I
never thought about strictly from a
strap from a perspective but it makes
sense for the other things like you know
if she's telling me she's been all
around the world yeah where can I take
her now right you know what I mean if
she tells me she's eating at all the
best restaurants what do you guys think
so if I've done those things with my
father is it different it is very
different oh yeah that's way different I
remember she said yeah when I was you
know I went to Dubai and then she said
wait a minute hold on cameraman with my
parents I went to Dubai with my parents
assistant
gonna be different than what you do
goodbye with who you're in a
relationship with because sometimes I'll
I'll tell stories I'll be like yeah it
was a box seats the other day with dad
with that Express yes but I like I don't
know I didn't know of that because
technically he can't do a first
experience it makes a big big difference
because going to Dubai with your father
clearly like you said is very very
different from going with someone that
you are dating your your father giving
you all of these experiences are very
very good but I don't think that works
against you as far as the simple context
is concerned not a chance
okay I was just making sure I don't
forget the first video that I uploaded
up on the channel it was an AMS reaction
and I had a young lady down from Miami
visiting me and I didn't know anything
about like camera framing or anything
like that and so I had so she was
actually sitting up higher than me
because her stool is a little bit higher
one of the top comments from the dudes
that were down up in there was I was a
short [__] who shouldn't be talking
about I'm not mad you this is the first
time you know the whole Space had not
seen reactions with women like six two
six three yeah yeah yeah but you know
but she looked taller than me in the
thing so I think like you know it's a
big thing for women but I actually think
for guys as well for much different
reasons I think the reason why women
like it to me it's a biological thing a
guy who is taller guys who are taller
are generally larger for the most part
it's a protection thing you know
um the first thing that the first thing
that Devin told me when we started
dating she's like I like that you make
me feel small
okay and I will say as someone I
probably have more tall friends than
anyone yes Sports yeah yeah so I had a
girl in high school six five big lady
there's one of my good friends the six
three I have other girls like it's like
five five is short for my friend group
the average height of a girl like that
is short everyone I know is like my
roommate's five nine five ten like it's
wow so
height is important unless you're
muscular that this conversation yes that
at like
we'll go down we won't go down too far
okay okay we won't go down so where's
the floor where's the floor where's the
floor for me
um I'm five eleven and a half so
probably five nine
if he's like good looking like strongly
that's probably okay five nine maybe
he's wider than he is tall right yeah so
it's like
but I've talked to I've talked to the
girls on my team about this it's like if
they're jacked it's like it makes up for
the height which is okay I don't know I
know that's superficial I'm just no no
no no no no being honest no no no that's
not that's not superficial it's
biological there is a re like there's a
reason why men are attracted to women
with large
but but those are those are genetic like
height is a genetic marker of physical
strength and capability right just like
you know large breasts indicate
fertility youthfulness uh The Hourglass
shape is a it's and we don't think about
this is all this is all going on in our
in our subconscious but this is why
we're automatically attracted to certain
things because men want to people want
to procreate with the most attractive
specimens there are Ergo the term
natural selection so call it superficial
if you want this is the way it is Mother
Nature I asked you guys this question
earlier so I'm gonna ask it on camera so
11 and a half so no stop okay so boobs
all right you can have a girl with boobs
and butt or or but she's a hoe or take
away the promiscuity but you have to
lose the boobs or the butt yeah which
what are you picking take away the
promise Judy okay so what are you
leaving losing the boobs are the bottom
I'm talking negative zero I can't buy it
either you can't buy anything no no no
no cheating no cheating okay gotta add a
caveat
am I still like do I have a YouTube
channel am I a public figure okay
you're you yes absolutely not the
promiscuity okay so what are you losing
boobs it's got to be the boot Oh either
or yeah so if she's not a hoe you have
to pick boobs or butt butt but but yeah
I'm picking butt I'm picking but I'd
rather have a cat you can't buy the
boobs I know but I probably will anyway
I probably will I'll be like I know this
was against the rules but this is the
rules of my games
we're going to we're going to see doctor
I've heard some guys say that they'd
rather have no boobs than fake boobs do
you think guys are capping about that um
I think now this is that's this is just
a preference thing because there are
some men that are that generally that
genuinely do not think that fake tits
are attractive now there are some
doctors that can do fake boobs and make
them look really natural Mariah Carey uh
comes to mind immediately uh but I mean
it is just a preference I like them dude
I like them sticking straight up when
they're laying down I like it I like I'm
sticking straight up dude I've been I
Bank dude I've banged more I've been oh
I've been more strippers than I care to
to admit and I've dated you just I mean
I've been Alpha widowed by strippers man
I'm sorry you've been uh can men be
Alpha Widow do you think
can men be Alpha widowed you know what
um
I think we probably could be but and
I've said this before
the best relationship a man will ever be
in can never be with the woman he loves
the most and the reason for that is
because when you really really true when
you really truly do love a woman and
that you would do anything for her you
just don't have the wherewithal to do
and say what needs to be done and said
I've said this multiple times and people
like oh my God you're disrespectful I
love Devin to the moon and back there
isn't anything I wouldn't do for her
she's maybe number four or five on my
list
I keep telling my boys that I'm probably
when I think about long-term
relationships it'll probably be with a
strong eight a strong eight eight and a
half okay because I think that at the
higher range of you know nines and tens
and above your will at some portions
will start to shift your frame may start
to shift you know depending upon the
particular situation I think that it's
easier to hold frame you know when it's
much more you know normal type looks as
opposed to on the supermodel Vogue type
level I think a strong ain't ain't
nothing wrong with a strong a listen man
my girl dude uh Devin AIDS still model
she's still she's still looking in
magazines it
when you say model I'm not talking about
the IG models yeah yeah I'm talking
about the actual amount yeah like like
yeah the actual models here's the
difference between who's a strong eight
to you
like famous
young Megan good uh Megan Goodson eight
no young man I would say is probably a
nine yeah I'll say a nine uh Stacy Dash
is a strong nine uh youngster young
Stacey Dash oh God she young Stacy Dash
that didn't have opinions it was a
strong nine strong nine Lark Voorhees
before she did whatever she did I don't
know these people uh let's say about it
let's say by the Bell dude she used to
can I can I pull him up on screen yeah
pull them up pull up do you remember
before and after no I haven't seen it I
didn't I grew up without TV for a while
oh we didn't have we didn't have 26 yeah
yeah she wasn't born yet it's not yeah
yeah I know you're gonna be shocked when
you see this Lark Voorhees before and
after yeah so that's Kelly
yeah that's the wrong oh so what's your
answer can men be Alpha widowed
like the opposite whatever the like man
equivalent of that I don't think so not
now because if if enough time goes by
eventually we will get over her like the
woman that I loved more than anybody and
I guess I'll tell the Sim tale when you
bring it around the question I feel
nothing for her because time has gone by
but when a woman gets Alpha widowed she
never forgets here's the thing though
let me offer a little bit of challenge
to that is that there are a lot of
there's a lot of men that will take
things
um violently after a relationship both
to themselves as well as to the other
party
um in a lot of these situations you know
is
um maybe Alpha Widow is not the correct
term for it but they go to an extreme
amount oftentimes way more extreme than
what women I think a lot of that has to
do with that with the biology of a man
that's more competitive more violent on
the far reaches and of the bell curve
but I think that and here's what I think
as well like I'm like answering it
question answering I think that women
because you guys are so like um
emotional and you talk to each other
regarding your emotions
you can get all of the [__] out
there whereas if men don't don't have
any outlet they don't even have their
boys as an outlet they can get real pent
up and just be aggressive in decent
different situations so it may not be
Alpha widowed but there's a lot there's
a lot of times out there yeah there's a
lot of dudes out there that you know
I've noticed a lot of guys when I ask
them because I ask people like who they
who they love the most a lot and a lot
of them pick like their High School like
it seems like their high school
girlfriend or like the first girl they
really like fell for is like the male
equivalent of an alpha Widow I'm sure
there are probably some similarities but
I don't think it's the same because the
women I think a lot of times would leave
their current guy for but men are more
logical where they're like that doesn't
make sense like why would I
obviously men and women are very very
different and we you know obviously we
process relationships very differently
but I think I women get over men much
more quickly than men get over I will
say that
um well I really and unless you're that
guy unless there you go I think and
that's that's the point you'll be dead
to us tomorrow yeah of course if I mean
we are over it we're over it but it's
like if you're that guy to her like she
will chase you to the ends of the year
yeah I guess she will I mean but you
know there's so as so many of us that
have gone through like you know I was
talking earlier how I got into the space
and it was during the like this red
pilling moment a lot of dudes they come
into the space because of heartbreak
right so which is why like I think what
we do is so important because it gives
an outlet for these men to be able to
say aha this is what I've been
experiencing right I'm not crazy how
many times have I've gone in these
conversations with like left-leaning
liberal college-educated women and I'm
just like holy [__] like if I was to
speak my mind during this conversation
they'd be they would kick me out the
house and I got a couple of stories of
that just happening just because I
speaked what I thought what was on my
mind which we all knew are uncomfortable
truths but because they're so deep down
into their feminist BS like they can't
come outside of the other education
college educated BS they can't get
outside of their self to consider but I
think that um there's a lot of dudes
that will just stay down in red pill
rage and just not be able to get out and
you know it can end off you know in not
having a satisfied life like it might
feel good that's what I always tell
dudes you got to get out the rage yes it
let it let it sweep over you yes let it
let it let it just Band-Aid yeah just
let it be there but have a plan to get
out of it because I see so many dudes
that just end up completely nihilistic
completely negative and you know they
just and you know they just stay within
that space you know what I'm saying
those guys turn into the black pillars
the black Bill Community are men who are
stuck in the anger phase and you know we
can we can bash those guys but you know
buy the same token I've been through
that kind of stuff man like I've been
through I've been through some [__]
and you know I was lucky enough to come
out of it and succeed and all that good
stuff but I understand why some guys are
just pissed off I'm not that doesn't
mean I condone it but you know I'm a
little bit more empathetic nowadays yeah
what do you think of the people like
Hafiz and them that will say that the
red pill is the same as feminism yes
like it's like the male version of
feminism
let's not make it personal right like
okay okay
but I hear men say that like the red
pill has turned into the like the male
equivalent of feminism where they're
just dunking on women all the time even
you you left the manosphere like what
happened there we could talk about all
of that so I think like to answer your
question I think that
the issue is is that there's a bunch of
different content creators that speak
about things from different ways so when
you say something like that my response
to him is can we go over a specific
example of who it is that you're talking
about because you can keep on saying all
of these things feminism is the right
you could keep on saying this but let's
go over
specific examples of specific content
creators that you think align like this
that's why like in my reaction to it I
was just like I wonder who he's talking
about when he's talking about the Neo
red pill literatures who are you talking
about like I I have no idea like it's
just confusing to me so you know when he
says things like that I mean let's go
over examples and let's do it by that
because it's such a generalized question
I don't like it when it's that General
let's get down and talk about specifics
um when anyone who says that the red
pill is is male feminism what they're
referring to are the black pill
community and the commenters that's what
they're basing this on they're not like
they're not basing this on me or Rolo or
fret no we are all highly successful
highly functioning then right no that
whoever said that they're talking about
the losers because when we when when one
of us goes viral all they talk about is
in cell culture
but they don't they don't recognize the
guys who are actually out here making a
difference so anyone who thinks that the
red pill is male feminism they're
strictly talking about black pale guys
who literally do nothing but complain
about women and red pill guys and then
the comment section and where does
feminism have women's self-improvement
that's a trick question because it
doesn't exist it doesn't that's what I'm
saying like there's nothing there's
nothing in feminism that says get better
but like all the red pill channels they
talk about all have self-improvement
that's it they all they'll say there's
no Solutions but they all offer
solutions they just can't solve the
unfair Justice
feminism yeah and they can't and then
there Allah why haven't they changed the
laws I'm like because we can't do
everything yeah right like oh that was
his other argument yeah that was right
yeah we're not [__] congressmen oh my
God we're like we're almost the whole
justice system
Senator here oh yeah but you know it is
he's trying to put all of that on you in
order to discredit kind of the
conversations that you've been having
but I consider us all like portions and
pieces of an organization you know I'm
not gonna I'm not going to be in finance
doing the law guy's job no at all you
know I was like wait ever you've been in
red pill longer than me like
me like
what's interesting is that do you guys
think that you know we'll be able to get
to the point uh because we talk about
you know enacting change and we do it by
kind of the individuality of the men
that you know come in in our section
also the women too that want to become a
marriageable material do you guys think
that we'll be able to get to a point in
our position where we'll be able to
change laws like work with stand-up
packs you know like actually do things
where it's more than just content in a
space but not us maybe specifically but
we're definitely be creating the burning
platform for change to occur right we
think like the mras you know a decade or
so ago I think part of the issue is
there wasn't the burning platform yes
for it right so do you guys think we'll
be able to like say like
um 100 paternity testing for all for all
for all births I think we I think it
will happen eventually but it's not
going to be in our lifetime there's it
it it blows me away that women are
offended at the very idea of required
paternity testing through the time of
birth it shouldn't be okay I just need
to get this off my chest it shouldn't be
a question who the father of your child
shouldn't be this shouldn't be a
question
can I talk about this real quick I love
Lori Povich Show by the way that is a
guilty pleasure oh my God I'll still
watch Mario though when it comes to
three-year-old Jaquan Tai quantavius you
are not the father they're popping it
they're popping and lagging yeah [__]
right right but but you also forget that
when he came out on the show they booed
him when he came down three times when
they were testing uh four different
fathers for her yes they boo the guys
but not her so we'd we'd completely
killed mori's job right if we were able
to stand something like this up I loved
it I love Mori it's a good place but the
reason why this is so passionate topic
of mine as well because my family was
impacted by paternity fraud as well yeah
I met my sister later in life I was
already in college by the time that I
met her and we had no idea that she was
a part of my family and I'm just like
damn you know not only did she not grow
up with her real father but then also
she didn't have access to us so it's
like but not not doing this you're not
only just robbing the child but then the
family that could have surrounded that
child as well
paternity fraud you want to know
something a woman's worst fear is
getting e-pard spelled backwards right
yep a man's worst fear is paternity
fraud that those are those I can't even
you should get jail time if you do that
I cannot imagine however many years that
that he spent raising that child double
it that will never happen it'll never
happen but I don't have like I don't
have kids but I can't um I cannot
imagine the gravity of the shock and the
pain that comes with finding out that a
child you thought was yours or somebody
else Stefan molyneux had a woman uh call
into a show one time I actually happen
to be watching it and she's she's been
married for like 15 years they have four
kids and she's like yeah my first kid
does not belong to my husband and I just
remember things and he told I mean she
talked about it so nonchalantly she says
well I guess like I kind of feel guilty
that is the world
that is it is the worst dude it is the
worst thing you can ever do to whom
it's so disgusting too if you think
about it like was it like four or five
days that you get pregnant out of the
month yeah so you just don't know within
that time and so you place it on someone
else even though you know that there's a
chance it's unbelievable that's so
disgusting like well here's well here's
the thing this doesn't excuse this but
when a woman is ovulating it I mean
especially in this day and age oh yeah
girls are gonna go out and get it that's
for sure you can always tell and this
this is a pro a pro pro tip for the guys
if you have a girlfriend get a cycle
calendar for your woman
um that that way and and study the
phases that way if like for example
forgive us for the crazy the week before
period forgive us it is I'm sorry we're
insane we hold y'all accountable for
that too
if you have a cycle calendar on your
woman then you understand what are
because a woman is never chemically
identical from one day to the next women
go through 30 different chemical changes
every every single day now they're
they're not all it's not all black and
white it's it's Ebbs and flows but the
other day Devin
um I think she was getting she was
getting snippy about something online
and she and I could just tell she was
just ah normally I'd be like yo you need
to check that now don't get me wrong
even when she is PMSing she never ever
gets out of pocket because I put her
back in Pocket very quickly but when I
know she is PMSing
you know I'm a little I'm a little
slower on the trigger that doesn't mean
I tolerate disrespect but I understand
what she's going through chemically and
so I make it I take it upon myself to
maybe put some distance between it so
that she can be a [__] in peace that's
that's that's what the cycle calendar is
guys are like dude I don't understand
women one day she wants to have my kids
the next day she wants to shoot me in
the face bruh get a cycle calendar it's
absolutely free if your woman wants to
have if a woman wants to have 80 your
kids one day but then wants to you know
stab you in the eyeball with an ice pick
the cycle calendar will tell you I will
shed some light on that this is a pro
pro tip for the guys
you got to know your woman
see she knows this is this is just how
it is man up and down no yeah even the
most sane girls all crazy it's it's look
at like we feel different every single
day right but it's like a lot of guys
will try to make like women men but
we're not men no no no you were
absolutely not and they like expect us
to talk I mean they don't expect us to
but but sometimes like when I'll read
the comments I'm like guys like the girl
is still like she's still a woman she's
not gonna talk like a man but here's
what the real issue is that sometimes I
think that some women fall into oh I can
have emotions so I can just act whoever
it is that I want I agree with you is
that oh you could be on your period and
act correct in the workplace but when it
comes to out in front of me so you can't
you know control yourself and I think
that's what it comes down to from uh
from a um
you know like it's just I don't know
it's just like well why can't you do
that in one Arena but you can't do it in
front of me and I think it's because you
know we allow it at the end of the day
yes here's another reason modern women
value their they value their jobs more
than they value their relationships they
absolutely do and here's the thing but
because think about this think about
this
the job tells her how to how to dress
how to act when to show up right if a
woman were to leave the house and a guy
says well wait a minute I don't want you
wearing that what's she gonna say you
can't tell me what to do but let her
show up to work and her supervisor says
whoa wait a minute you can't wear that
low that low-cut blouse yes sir right
away sir and this is this this is what
is causing another disconnect with women
is they respect their bosses more than
their men and guys don't know why that's
true yep that's absolutely yeah man like
it's it's funny because I tell guys you
have to vet women you have to put them
on probation and and all this other kind
of stuff and they always balk at the
thought of having to qualify I used to I
used to cry at work too
well there you go
that's just how it goes women women like
in the bathroom but no one would see
have you had conversations like that in
the bathroom with people has anyone
caught you crying in the bathroom no I
was the only girl at the office so I was
calling my own bathroom oh this is your
sales job yeah yeah yeah
I've cried a couple times on sales jobs
it's no joke but yeah women respect
women respect their bosses but women
will do they will move Heaven and Earth
for their boss for a company that
doesn't really give a [__] about them
but then the guy who but the the the guy
that who you know who's legally
obligated to be there with her he takes
care of her she didn't want to respect
him sorry
yeah that's true
shout out to feminism shout out right
though they put the workplace over the
man
um I'll tell you guys a story uh about
the worst
I'm gonna give you I'm gonna give you
guys the Reader's Digest version of the
girl that I love the most
this story is it's it's absolutely crazy
to make a very long story very short I
started paralegal school when I was 31
years old and there's this there's this
hot hot 19 year old in my class we took
a shine to each other immediately right
it was a great relationship we spent
every day together blah blah blah blah
red flag number one that I didn't even
think about one day I had a headache in
class because I suffer from migraines
and she recognized that she says what's
wrong I said well I've got a headache
she's like all right reaches him to her
purse and she gives me this big white
pillow I'm like what is that she says
it's Vicodin and I was like all right so
I took the Vicodin headache is gone
what's a 19 year old doing with a bag
full of Vicodin right she's a drug
dealer right no problem at all red flag
red flag number two she had homemade she
had she had she had homemade tattoo on
her wrist right told me she got it when
she was told me she got it when she was
15. hold on red flag number three stay
with me red flag number three she had a
six-year-old
she was 19 years old who had a
six-year-old which means what class she
had her child at 13. which means she was
having sex at 12. it gets even better
the baby daddy
was in prison at the time we were dating
oh statutory statutory epar here's the
reason why they didn't throw the book at
him with Jessica's law is because she
testified to the jury that she seduced
him and the jury actually bought it the
jury actually bought it so let's let's
let's set the scene
August so my birthday
my birthday I open up Facebook to get
all the all the birth they love she left
her account open on my computer on
Facebook I scrolled through saw all
kinds of stuff drove to her place I said
I want you to be honest with me have you
cheated on me I wanted her to lie to me
and I I wanted her to lie to me so I
could just keep up the delusion she said
honestly yes that is the worst the worst
emotional pain I've ever felt in my life
to this day I never will dude I dude I
went to her bathroom I puked ripped off
the necklace she's blowing him she's
blowing me up at work all day long I'm
sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry I can't pick
up the phone so finally I picked up the
phone she's like hey I'm sorry you know
I want to spend the rest of my life with
you she's like look I want to come to
your place I have a birthday surprise
for you so she comes over she has like
this little cupcake and she bought me a
watch that she knew I was looking at
then she turns around and lifts up her
shirt there was my name tattooed on the
small of her back dude my hand to the
man so I was back in her I was back in
her clutches things went all it was all
downhill from there guys this story gets
so much worse how old were you I was 31
I was 31 years old yeah I know you're
gonna say 17. oh no no no no no so
so so she continued she she continued
cheating on me right so I'm always
trying to catch her I lost my job I lost
the place that I was at I the car that I
had was paid for because I paid cash for
it it broke down I didn't have a job so
I couldn't get it fixed I'm evicted I
ended up having to live with a couple of
her a couple of her drug addict friends
in a quasi-crack house both people were
on felony probate what you can't make
this up both people the the guy and the
girl were on probation for felony
possession they were on felony probation
ankle bracelets the whole night
and and so and so I lived there and so I
had to live there right and so finally
and I kept I I kept trying to get back
with her September 16th baby daddy gets
out of prison okay maybe that he gets
out of prison I called her up on
September 15th I said you know what I
can't do it I think you still I think
you still love Ben I can't do it anymore
dude she cried her eyes out hung up the
phone I stayed up all night long I
couldn't sleep
so I called her up I called her up the
next day I was like hey um you know meet
me at this meet me at this gas station
then I called up my brother and I
borrowed 800 he gave me 800 I went to
the jewelry store I bought her a ring
proposed to her
I proposed listen
I'm telling you listen it gets worse it
gets worse I swear to God people want
listen people wonder why I speak with
such conviction about these things dude
look
it looks it gets worse it gets worse so
she says yes right
so now you know all of our friends are
like oh she's getting engaged well
eventually she started [__] the baby
daddy behind my back of course so we
were in this we were in this love
triangle anytime she was pissed off at
me she'd go and [__] him anytime she was
pissed off at him she would come and uh
she would come and me so finally on
Thanksgiving
um uh I had to call my bro my family
wasn't my family this was in North
Carolina my brother comes out into this
into this quasi-crack house and he's
kind of looking around and they're all
looking up at him like that's your
brother and of course we look alike and
so I'll never forget man I'm telling my
brother about the situation he's like my
real things Alex what are you doing and
I said to him I said dude you can't you
don't choose who you love I still loved
her
so he drives me back after Thanksgiving
dinner this girl calls me up and tells
me that she was now engaged to be
married to Ben right I'm crushed I'm
heartbroken I'm crestfallen I'm doing
pills I'm doing drugs from the time that
you recognize the tattoo and she had a
six-year-old to do this time how long
has time has progressed I met her the
first day of the second semester so
right in January so this happened
between January this happened in one
calendar year this happened in one
calendar year so
I'm telling you can't make this stuff up
so now I've lost her I've lost her
forever I've lost her forever so now I'm
doing and all this other kind of stuff
during the time I was living at that
quasi-crack house they were telling me
yeah she this guy that guy during the
summer during the summer she lost an
exorbitant she was already a small girl
she lost an exorbitant amount of weight
I found out that she was shooting heroin
all summer long I had no idea she kept
dude it was it was unbelievable so
anyway so New Year's Day comes right so
New Year's Day comes around oh wait a
minute let me back up December 10th the
guy so it's a boyfriend and girlfriend
the in the crack house the guy I was at
the library the the sorry listen the
probation officer arrested the guy so
then he went so he's in jail for for
probation violation so it's just me and
his girlfriend I had no interest in her
it was it was not like that at all well
he was feeling some type of way about
the fact that I was staying there so he
called his landlord word and told him
that I was staying there without their
permission New Year's Day little to make
a man comes to the door he points me
he's like you don't live here and if
you're not out of here by nine o'clock
the next morning the sheriff will come
and put you out called my brother again
I was like dude I'm I mean I'm going to
be homeless so he bought me a bus ticket
uh to Atlanta and I go down I go down to
uh to Atlanta where my mother and
brother were living and kind of started
over then
so I lived in Atlanta for six months
decided to move to Vegas it was a bit
that's a whole big long story a couple
of months into living in Vegas I get a
phone call from a mutual friend of ours
me and the girls right and she's like
you are never gonna believe this I was
like what happened she said Ben is dead
I was like this is her husband now right
the baby daddy they got married she says
Ben is dead here's what happened two
weeks after she married this guy she
started having an affair right she
started cheating on him she's a lovely
lady dude
so the story goes is that he gave her 20
bucks to go out and get Chinese food she
took her daughter with her goes to the
guy's house calls him up calls him up
and says hey I'm leaving you and I'm
gonna I'm gonna be here with this guy
with the daughter of course he loses his
mind he drives up to the trailer he
starts kicking in the door the guy on
the other side of the door says if you
kick down this door I am going to shoot
you he kicked down the door and caught a
shotgun slug to the chest done and
killed immediately
it gets even worse
they had to put an angle bracelet on her
because they suspect that she might be
the shooter right let's back up one more
time and again this is all relevant I'm
Dr this is when I still had my car I'm
driving to to her place from work
driving her place from work
I get to her I get to her place and
there are three cop cars in the driveway
I'm thinking it's because of their uh
because of something that happened next
door because the Dude is always beating
on his girl right that's the kind of
place this was the cops were at her
place she got arrested for possession
the guy the people I was staying with
had called the cops and ratted her out
so now she's in jail right
and of course and of course I have to
save my fair Maiden I called up an old
roommate and borrowed
1350 to bail her out she gets out I love
you I love you then goes right back to
Ben then goes right back to Ben so now
we fast forward Ben was dead I backed up
he back okay this was before Oh so so
now so so you bailed out yep the the
young lady who had left you to go back
and then when you you borrowed the one
before it was back and forth borrow the
money so you had to pay back this money
to someone else who has nothing to do
with the situation and then she went
back straight while she had the tattoo
of you on her yep okay keep going I got
like 15 questions to ask you when this
is I'm almost done
Ford so Ben is now dead
don't know how they all they got away
with it but he's not like he's not like
the guy's not in jail
she ends up marrying the guy that killed
Ben and had another daughter so in the
end this was the original baby dad the
original baby daddy is Dead the Original
baby daddy Ben was the original baby
baby daddy okay and a lovely lady went
to the guy who killed Ben yes no okay so
and and so now so he ended up marrying
the guy who killed her her her first
husband had another daughter with him so
the so the father of her first child was
killed by the father of her second child
you cannot make this up and so this is
why people always wonder why I'm such a
I'm such a I'm so passionate and I'm so
sure I have seen the worst I've been in
the worst of the worst situations it is
the worst situation I have ever been in
but to this day I can freely admit that
I have never loved anyone or anything as
much as I loved her
I need this girl to give some girl games
she's getting Rings left and right I
have viscous innards made of plutonium
uh it certainly felt like it
it certainly felt like it the girl like
I don't know she was 19. she was 19 she
was hot had a southern twang I mean we
could hate but she's gotten more
proposals than I have
proposals well proposals from guys who
were clearly either simping or who had
gone to jail with a jail for having
relations with her at 12 years old like
questions would Donovan have been
Donovan if Donovan was exposed to
Donovan's work today at 31 years old
yeah I would not have made that mistake
I would not have made that mistake with
her and and you know what's interesting
I A lot of times I think actually you
know what no I think I still would have
gone down that road because
the reactions well here's well here's
the thing here's the thing as men we're
hard-headed a lot of most lessons that
men that men uh encounter you can't
teach some lessons can't be taught some
lessons you gotta learn that was a
lesson dude everybody could have told me
stay away from her stay away from her I
was in love man like dude she was night
dude she's the hottest girl at school
she's showing me off I mean I was in
love I had to and I am dude I am so I am
so fortunate to have made it out of that
armpit of a county in rural North
Carolina it it's it is literally the
lowest I have ever been in my life and
to and to be able to to be able to sit
here with all of my accomplishments
despite having gone through that that's
a miracle it's a [__] miracle
you pulled yourself up out of hell I did
I did
holy [__] like ever I got anxiety here
in that entire story so as you're going
through this you're not thinking to
yourself oh because of you know the
e-wrap epar that happened in real life
man maybe she did something's going
maybe because maybe of a lack of a
father man man I shouldn't maybe because
she just decided to get a tattoo me
after she cheated on me I met her father
I met her father her father was in and
out of prison her entire life in and out
of prison her entire life do you think
that men okay because I've noticed this
and you could tell me if I'm right or
wrong I feel like sometimes men like the
girls with I don't want to say like the
girls with the troubled past but like
the reason there's an attraction to it
is because they want to feel like they
saved her or like helped her like men
like to feel needed and a lot of them
and a lot of those girls like really can
make a man feel needed because they do
need you to survive like a lot of them
would you would you hear your thinking
I'm not saying all guys I'm just saying
that's hold on before you answer I have
one more story I have one more story
these were the two relationships that
that red pilled me the most girl I
worked with this was long before the
other girl uh girl I worked with uh dude
hot Puerto Rican girl I mean she was bad
as hell fast forward through all of that
stuff I never [__] her but she called
me up one day she called me up she
didn't come to work and she called me up
she's I was like what's going on why
aren't you at work I got kicked out or
my sister kicked me out and I was like
oh no your sister kicked you out
so what I did is I rented this girl true
story I rented this girl a three-bedroom
two-bathroom House near downtown Raleigh
North Carolina the lease is in my name I
got cable in my name I got uh I got her
uh an electricity was in my name
I found out so so she so I moved her all
in and everything and I'm paying all
this girl's bills it's unbelievable I'm
driving home one time I had a I had
supposed to give out girl games that's
not girl games she got a house payment
[Applause]
yeah dude I was not clearly I would not
do these things do you think it reflects
more on girls having good game or just a
stage of life that you are in to allow
these things to be a part of your
character
probably a little bit of both there's
there's no such the only
girl game has nothing to do with sexual
Allure okay all a girl has a girl can
get dude girls as soon as a girl opens
her phone she's getting hit in the face
with dicks it doesn't take game to do
that right that I mean it's just okay
okay it doesn't take game to get late
like but that's no no no hold on will
you open up your phone you can hit his
face with dicks no I mean you get
messages but here's the thing the reason
but listen the reason I did these things
is because I wanted to [__] her and she
knew I wanted a [__] her that was it any
girl can get that sexual any girl can
get validation but to be able to keep
and retain it from a man of value that's
the girl yeah I feel like I would feel
bad accepting that if I'm not in she
absolutely did not like like I would
feel bad accepting that from a guy
because then it's like I feel like he's
expecting something and if I don't want
to do that then like why are you excited
I always told her I always told her no
pressure no pressure but while she was
in the house and I never spent the night
I found out she was her ex con baby
daddy
it was a plan from the start her sister
told me about this plan she didn't have
the credit or the money to get a place
of her own her baby daddy I think his
name was Ray was getting out of prison
in a week and she needed a sucker she
needed a sucker to finance a place for
her and her baby daddy to live so as
soon as I found out about the plan of
course I you know I cut off all contact
but even still even still I held out
hope that she might actually come around
and people people look at the way I am
now and they're like dude I can I could
I just I refuse to believe that that was
you that was absolutely me it was
absolutely me that's real yeah I think
that uh to answer your question because
I think it was specific to guys want to
fix
I think that there was a a Trope within
media that guy should be the fixers they
should sacrifice you know their money
their time to save a woman a damsel in
distress you know we talk about the
Disney and the impact of that on to the
minds of men today but I think like you
know through the content of space it's
breeding a new man yeah within that is
to say no I don't see your masculine
behavior I'm not talking about your girl
your girl's on some other [__] I don't I
don't I don't see I don't see that
masculine Behavior or something to over
encumber I don't need to over encumber
that no I will go select the better
option right but like at the same time I
don't know like have you sat down and
thought through you know that time in
your life and understanding it was one
of the worst times all the time life
you're saying yeah like what what were
the things that led you to go there
because I think that would help men in
understanding like is it the way that
you were raised it was scarcity man
scarcity I'd never like I wasn't like
dude honestly the girl's name was the
girls name uh she [__] let's go let's
go yeah
the girl's name like the girl's name I
was dude I had I had never ever had sex
with a woman that attractive Not only
was she attractive she took care of me
she used to bring me coffee before class
she used to buy me like remember I
remember one time I texted little girl
game we could learn you know okay so I
so I was like I mean this girl's doing
something to have this many men chasing
her come on come on Pearl no no we can
no no hold on real quick we can laugh
and chuckle but that's like that's not
girl game like she got like she got a
man killed and she'll probably get
somebody else killed right well but
you're saying it's scarcity because her
doing those little things and then also
I have a good business that you never
experience it you didn't want to let go
of it no I would dude I was married to a
woman who got fat and didn't have sex
with me for a year and a half right so a
year after like a year after the divorce
was final realized all of a sudden
there's this beautiful girl taking
interesting right dude dude she would
come to my place and cook for me it was
something I I was married and my wife
didn't cook for it yeah and so this was
something these were things I had never
experienced and so what factored into
that was the scarcity I had never had an
attractive woman treat me like that your
wife didn't even cook for you nope every
once in a while she would but she didn't
she didn't do it on the regular no she
didn't that's so sad and by the way my
ex-wife
also committed paternity fraud you can't
make this stuff up oh wow make this
stuff up nope mm-hmm no way but
interestingly enough the one
relationship that led me to the that
actually finally pushed me over the edge
wasn't consequential it was a girl I
hooked up with uh when I was in Vegas
and um uh we were we we worked at the
same call center
three weeks after you know we hooked up
for the first time I decided I decided I
want to be there so I drove to her house
I said all right look Martha you know it
was fun but you know it's over and she
didn't seem the least bit surprised and
I remember thinking to myself okay
that's great she's somebody else's
problem now but why did she get over me
so quickly when a week and a half before
she told me she loved me I went home and
I googled why do girls get over breakup
so easily I was on I was on my computer
for almost 24 hours straight and that
was that was when I was like oh wow and
that was the day Donovan sharp was
created that was the beginning imagine
if you never did that you still you may
still be on that damn path I was looking
you know it's funny I was looking I was
looking for answers
um I think a few years before I had
bought a book called How to Be an alpha
male by a guy by by his name was John
Anthony and it resonated with me so much
but that was right before I met
Stephanie so I used some of the
techniques to make myself attractive to
Stephanie I just didn't know what to do
afterwards or what to look for and she
taught me a very valuable and expensive
lesson I remember when I told my mother
she was like oh my God I was like what
she's like Alex you could have been you
could have been Ben and I thought to
myself you know what
that probably could have been that
probably could have been so
that's yeah that's uh that's my so when
so so when people when people ask well
how does he know this stuff and why does
he that's why I I have my own anecdotal
experiences and the thing is is that
even though those stories are crazy the
reason this community exists is because
so many men have similar stories right
we didn't just wake up one day and
decide you know what let's make up a
bunch of crazy gnarly stories about
women and form this community and call
them no we all found each other because
we said wait a minute that guy went
through the same thing as I did or or my
buddy did one thing leads to another
people get together and now we have the
red pill Community I didn't realize how
common this marriage thing was
I don't so do you think when your wife
wasn't sleeping with you she was
sleeping with someone else
she could have been she could because
it's to me I'm like don't the girls want
to have sex like why do they just stop
sleeping with their husbands because
they're well because their husbands are
unattractive that's what it is the
reason she see we were I've got the Hail
Mary
um uh tattoo because I used to be
Catholic I went all in we so during rcia
I don't even know what it stands for
anymore it's it's it's like a series of
classes you go to become Catholic and
all that good stuff and you're supposed
to abstain from
and that's what she used as and that
lasted for a year and a half so
yep is a bad reason but that's uh that's
how it was man wow yep yep so now uh I
mean like that's what I didn't
understand when I first when I first
went into red pill I didn't understand
why men were so opposed to marriage and
and it like it was it was so far well
partially but it was so foreign to me
because I was like my parents were
married everyone like most people I know
were married like there were some like
where I grew up it was Catholic school
and it was there was some like divorced
families um but it was like not enough
yeah well yeah and I didn't really know
the story like when you get older you
hear more of the stuff that happened
behind the scenes but when you're young
they don't tell you no of course not you
know and so but then when I started to
realize like the men they don't even get
their kids if there's a divorce like 90
of the time then I started to learn like
how um the Duluth model was implemented
and like women can charge men of
um domestic violence with actually
without giving men like the right to a
fair trial to face their future like all
that stuff in civil court and then I
started learning about
how once the guys get married the girls
will get fat and then stop sleeping with
them and then how men value youth in
Purity but the average age of first
marriage in the UK is 31 so they don't
get either and you start doing them yeah
and I just started like thinking about
it and like putting myself in the guy's
shoes and I'm like if I was a guy and I
was gonna risk everything like would I
want to do it for you know the the
average girl today
and who's overweight or if she's not
overweight statistically she will be
she's not pure like what what guy gets a
virgin nowadays she's not like and I
just she they don't cook they don't
clean and I was like if I was a guy I
would would I want to get married and
I'm like and if she leaves she can take
half your stuff she can take the kids
and then what they'll do is they'll say
well how common is this and it's like
okay well the whole point is that's a
lot of power to give someone yes it is
and that's not really a fair deal and
happy wife happy life though
well I've got another saying I call it
but why is that there because all the
woman has all the power so you can't
you're gonna ask happy wife happy life
because because she has all the power
yep that's it uh that's why I say
girlfriends are better than wives
because if she's a girlfriend then you
can just end the relationship without
any uh any uh perceived collateral
damage and a lot of guys in the
community say oh my god when Devon
leaves Donovan she's taken half a [__]
no she can't we live in a state that
does not recognize common law marriage
when we move we'll be we'll move to a
state that does not recognize common law
marriage but
men we are fair and we are just and I've
said this I've said this in public if I
ever decide to leave Devin I'm going to
make sure she's taken care of
financially because dude she quit her
job she helps me she helped me to build
the Empire she's paid her dude she puts
up with my crap and she she treats me
like she treats me like a [__] God so
if it ever comes to a point to where I'm
like you know what I'm kind of tired of
this feminine submissive woman who does
literally anything I ask her to do I'm
gonna make sure I break her off if she
decides to leave she ain't getting [__]
though well I think most men are very
fair honestly even with like the child
support stuff I think most men want to
sit like take care of their kids but
it's like the women get so spiteful and
greedy where they'll just like drag a
man to court out of spite for no reason
for no reason there is there is a girl
that came on my show that said she
stopped letting the dad see the kids
because she felt like the kids were
better off without him unbelievable and
like it wasn't abuse like she was she
like then what the girls will do is
they'll say some messed up [__] and be
like I don't want to get into it I'm
like what the [__] why'd you say it
didn't speak for themselves yeah right
and even the women that are not that
spiteful then they have the lawyer in
their ear yeah and a lawyer can make
money off of this yes and they begin to
understand the industrial divorce uh
business that is run in this country
right if you go and you're looking in
title 4D and you're like oh [__] they
make more money the more that they can
extract from child support that's right
oh and it's all it's all it feels it
almost looks like an elaborate plan
that's why every other [__]
commercial is he went to Jared or every
kiss begins with k it's almost like
they're in business with one another
it's crazy it you know have you ever
have you ever driven down a street where
all of the potholes are in the tire
track right it's almost like you think
that like the tire manufacturers design
the street right or or change your oil
after a change your oil every 3000 Miles
no that's [__] you don't really need
to change your oil until about five or
six thousand miles so what do you guys
think about like we and this was always
a criticism of like the manosphere red
pill is that they would say you know
Mary before you carry but now men don't
want to get married
so what do I say to who yeah no like do
you like because there's two conflicting
messages in in the I mean there's so
many different people but you would have
Kevin Samuels say things like
Mary before you carry right and I think
that's fair yeah I think I think that's
fair of course but at the same time you
hear the men say we don't want to get
married do not get married and and I
understand both sides so like how do you
reconcile that easily private marriage
you get married just don't get the state
involved have the have the have the
wedding have the ceremony have the Pomp
and Circumstance Cut the Cake do the
little thing where you wrap it around
with the wine you know break the bottle
and all that stuff just don't sign any
papers right you can because honestly
can you legally change your last name
yes you can you can change your last
name you can go to this social security
hour of attorney you know it you can do
all of the marriage things I guess
except for like the tax the combination
of my taxes that's the only thing that's
the only thing besides that you could do
all of that separately and the funny
thing is is the only reason why we think
people are married is because there's
evidence of it but we don't see the
marriage certificate oh we saw the
wedding and that's proof enough right so
if the wedding is proof enough that you
got married then why sign the paper so
if you guys guys had daughters you would
be cool with that yes 100 100 yes yep
I'm just 100 and the thing is is you
have to understand female nature and
it's funny a lot of a lot of people I
have had discussions with they say well
you have mother what if you had a
daughter and I'm like look man the truth
is the truth whether whether the truth
applies to all women whether they're
related to us familiarly or not I love
my mother and I love my sisters they
were hoes man my mom was a hoe listen my
mom was a hoe when she was married she
dude my mom cheated on my dad and had at
least two options both of my sisters
have had at least I was there for one of
them so I know and under like I have
witnessed I've witnessed this stuff
firsthand and there are a lot of guys
who who would like to think well that
doesn't apply to my mom yes [__] it Mom
I love you to death you brought me into
this world I I will be forever grateful
but that doesn't mean I can't
acknowledge that she was at home do you
think do you think that if a girl has an
abortion that takes her off of
the thing is is that we'll never know
because she'll just lie about it okay
what if you do now so if I knew that she
had mult uh an abortion in the past yeah
an abortion she's done like no a lot of
guys don't care I've asked for this well
if a lot of guys don't care those are
guys without options if you dude if you
commit to a woman who made the
unilateral decision to end the life of
another person without their consent
that is a special kind of evil I'm I'm
with you I agree like I'm I'm very
pro-life but I've just I that isn't the
consensus that I when I ask this
question
yeah I mean they they could just be
because then it's it's interesting
because if guys don't give a certain
answer then the other guys will be like
oh they're just Captain they might be I
don't know but I don't know maybe I've
just I've just asked guys on the Shelf
it's disqualified real talk yeah I don't
care I don't care have you ever asked a
question on your show of the women that
are in there like how many A's have you
had throughout your life how many A's
um no oh yes yes we did we I actually
had a whole show where we brought in
like these women to actually show the
pictures from it and this is the thing
like they don't
they it's really hard to find like good
videos and pictures of what it actually
looks like it's actually really grossy
and like one of the girls talked about
how like the thing is that that is an
important show because I think like it's
sort of like when you go into like
supermarkets today yeah we don't watch
the poultry being created so it takes
out a lot of what it took to get that
from the pasture into the supermarket I
think to a degree it's the same thing
for that act is
you don't see it so you don't understand
what what it is you don't understand
what happened it's just kind of Bing
Bang Boom get it done and that's
what she said they didn't like tell her
and this and there's a random group like
it wasn't like I didn't plan this or
tell them the topic it was just like
I didn't know this before she got there
but she was saying like they didn't tell
her anything and they kept it very vague
and because the thing is like you have
to think about it those are broken
clinics they're operating as a business
and they make most of their money from
and they'll say it's other stuff but
like think about it what's going to make
you more money a surgery or some pills
you ever seen those those commercials
with the the pets that are used you know
they'll show I can't watch those
commercials I can't watch the Saint
Jude's commercial because when I see
sick children or or or or or animals you
know being abused I just I just can't
handle that's why that's why it was
shocking to me that I've asked so many
guys and they don't care really if a
girl's had
the guys haven't seen it the same way
the girls haven't seen I mean we're all
kind of raised in the same educational
institution let me let me let me let me
subscribe this to you guys
neutrobos spelled backwards are
performed by doctors am I wrong
what I'm trying to figure out what the
Roy business is the a words oh about
backwards okay right right they're
performed by doctors right what is the
in the Hippocratic Oath the one line
that everybody knows is Do no harm noit
robas are the only medical procedure
that that goes directly in the face of
the Hippocratic Oath that no doctor gets
in trouble for Do no harm right so how
is it that doctors that perform these
medical procedures how is it that
they're able to keep their licenses if
they are literally doing harm I don't
think anyone has thought of it that way
people don't understand that the
Hippocratic Oath says Do no harm yeah
but no they've definitely thought about
it and I think that then it comes up the
whole discussion of well can you know
can they do harm to something that is
not a life and then is the definition of
what is a life I'm telling you if you
saw the I haven't even seen the videos I
don't want to see it but it's it's I
mean and I just don't really have a lot
of sympathy because it's like my mom got
pregnant when she was 17 by my dad and
they um like they gave the kid up for
adoption and like this is what people
don't understand about adoption like
they'll say oh the foster care system if
you give up a baby like fresh out the
womb like it's not that hard to get
someone to adopt them the problem is the
crackhead mothers that that like kind of
put their kid in bad situations until
they're five and then the foster care
system like takes them yeah and so I
mean from what I mean there could be
more I don't understand but from what I
understand like that it's it's not hard
to find Two Loving parents especially
with all the infertility yeah a baby
yeah yeah but it's like nobody wants a
kid that's like been from a crack house
the last five years and is going to be
traumatized for life because we've been
on both sides where we've adopted and
given a kid up for adoption and I will
say like it's very risky to adopt a kid
that's had trauma in their early years
even if they even if they don't remember
it it still changes the kid's brain like
most of your development is done before
the age of three four like I think it's
before the age of three so it yeah so I
I find it so interesting that it's my
body my choice after conception and it's
never my body my choice when they have
to pick more than 30 forms of
contraception beforehand and here's the
thing my body my choice I understand
that but we don't own our children okay
like you know what I mean like just
because a woman just because a woman
gets pregnant you don't own that child
the the 13th amendment abolished slavery
involuntary servitude you can't own
other people and so when women say my
body my choice okay fair enough if you
want to destroy your body that's fine
but what about the Kids Choice again
you're making a decision for someone
else that my body my choice argument is
because you do not own your children
now
I heard there's a girl that had seven
oh my God seven and she uses a she uses
I think it's 40 of women that have had a
have had one or more more than one um I
thought I saw one stat that said two or
more but regardless like the 60 who has
them in the future they don't know oh my
God so I just I just can't I'm just a
big believer in like the consequences
for your decisions like why are we
always bailed out and adoption's always
you know again we've been on both sides
we've been on both sides of adoption
like you you can make it work you wanna
know why you wanna know why girls get
they don't want to ruin their bodies
that's it you can dude that's that's
really what it comes down to they can
talk about well they're I don't want to
bring a child into this world and I'm
not ready and blah blah blah blah you
know put them up put them up for
adoption well the foster care system
there are just like you said girls can
get bailed out of anything what it
really comes down to the reason why
girls is because they don't want to ruin
their bodies because childbirth destroys
a woman's body that that is is all there
that's the only good reason I can think
of that's extremely selfish so they get
off like that's why that's again where I
understand like where the men are coming
from because when you think about it
like modern women I've asked so many
girls like would you go down in
lifestyle for a family and they're like
hell no no and that's the crazy thing
like to me it's like yeah like why would
you not want kids you want to die alone
you'd rather do that than I don't know
not get to travel twice a year oh my God
like that's not worth children like and
to me like I don't know I just think
it's sad I understand like why men are
walking away from marriage I'm not I
don't really push it either way but it's
just like I understand where they're
coming from it's a sad State of Affairs
man it really is I have a oh God I was
gonna say I have a friend in my life
that
um end up getting a girl pregnant and
he had no say in what she did with it at
all because of his religious beliefs was
just like we're here now let's do this
and she did not want to at all and the
thing is is like the way that the laws
are today is such that he has no choice
within that there is no I think like in
China
some country in Asia both parents have
to sign before it's the deed is done but
over here the man has no say in that at
all
it's it's
I don't it's it's a it's it's a very
it's a very very tough conversation and
and again
the the reason and it's funny my stance
has nothing to do with politics or
religion it I mean it doesn't matter
take the religion the politics out of it
it is wrong to end the lives of people
before they're born I don't know how
anybody can say with a straight face
that they're okay with that but then it
goes back to why are they so vehement
about this at some point it's not really
about the issue it's really about
pissing off the other side you see these
angry you know marching you know for for
this stuff it's almost as though it Gets
Lost in Translation they just want to
piss off the other side yeah if I've had
six questions because they know it's
gonna piss off the other side it's sad
but it's like I said and you asked the
question earlier when are things going
to change I think things eventually will
change but it's not going to happen in
our lifetime not the way things are
going now we live in clown world man we
really do enjoy the decline man
hopefully you guys can find someone they
can tolerate for 10 minutes at a time
and maybe have a happy life but in this
day and age the odds are not in your
favor um where's Thanos at
send the asteroid
send the send the asteroid well
it's for a minute thank you guys what
yeah wow that flew by boom that's sad um
thank you guys for coming on this is a
fun pod yeah yeah absolutely
um let me know who you guys maybe this
will be like my Miami like why would I
come to Miami this would be this would
be a lot of like a three-person podcast
let me know who else you guys would want
to see on you know put some content
creators in the comments uh by the way
uh pick up my free ebook pick up my free
ebook dead bedroom the cure for a
sexless relationship uh you can get it
at tsracademy.com or get it at
donovansharp.com it's absolutely free
putting your very best email the book is
yours little game for you there right no
no not because you're in a relationship
or in a relationship that's the emails
that's the email thing I was telling you
yeah again it was it was clarifying
clarified to Dubai with my parents my
parents yeah
okay go ahead
materials and reviews you guys already
know look for me at the real MTO on
Instagram as well
thanks for coming
guys like the video your way out let me
know who you want me to have on the Pod
next subscribe to the channel and ring
that notification Bell and sign up for
my fourth membership tier if you want to
learn how I killed the YouTube game also
if you want to see me freestyle rap sign
up for my second tier and also
for the behind the scenes Vlogs about to
drop a beat right now like it like it
like yeah
look at it dude I swear to god dude
every day
alienation hey
stagnation I'm sitting in here
it was good freestyle I
said I could I never said I was good
well I might sign up one to ten what
would you give me
on what the performance yeah solid three
three oh on that can I get a four no is
the one on the membership tier four or
better another membership here is a
little better okay listen I'll give you
a two because it was terrible but it was
better than I thought it would be yeah
thank you I'll shake it she made some
tough worms words rhyme together it was
the filler on the sides of the words
though once she got into the into the
Tio inwards that's when things kind of
went downhill
okay guys like the video on your way out
subscribe to the channel we'll talk to
you next time